curiosity which one mentioned is a
amazing thing that becomes as bold scary
thing that you need to go off and live
every day and it's easy to fall off the
horse curiosity is not so much a trait
as a as a situation
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message have curiosity over to
you Bill Gates also if you want to know
what Bill Gates and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I believe in the
Internet
I believe it'll get increasingly popular
and we're doing some neat new things to
take advantage of that
we find the world in just such an
interesting place so we like to compare
notes on it when we have compare notes
we have a lot of fun doing it one of the
things that happened in I bill was it I
guess your dad at the dinner said you
know what is it you should what's been
the most important quality for you and
you found out that you and Warren had
the same word yeah I think curiosity
which Warren mentioned is a an amazing
thing where you try and predict what's
going to happen and then when it doesn't
you sort of think well you know that
drug didn't get invented that stock
could go up that approach wasn't popular
what's what is it about my model of the
world that's wrong you know who could I
talk to what could I read and and the
things that have happened since 1991
mostly good things have been amazing and
just you know so much fun to talk about
you know so you know it we read the news
and we think God what did Warren think
about that when you find your one word
your business your life your level of
clarity will explode the key thing in
this video isn't only just for you to
have more curiosity
it's that Bill Gates and Warren Buffett
they're one word is curiosity they have
built their friendship their life their
business around curiosity and that's why
they have achieved success use my
youtube channel as an example as well my
one word is believe it's in every video
I do every piece of content I make when
I first discovered believe I tested it
with a YouTube video that video quickly
became the number one video on my
channel at that time my best video had a
hundred thousand views it took me a year
to get there this video got a hundred
thousand views in one month and now is
sitting at over two million views it was
the first video on my channel to pop not
because believe is the best word or
because curiosity is the best word it's
the word for me it's the word for Bill
and Warren what is your word when you
figure that out it's the path it's the
compass it helps guide every
decision that you make in your life with
absolute clarity and if you don't then
you're constantly living someone else's
version of your life if you don't know
what your core value is you will fall
prey to what other people want you to do
you will always worry about other
people's judgements you'll always feel
like there's something more that you're
capable of but you won't know how to
access it this is the path
self-awareness core value is the path
understanding your one word is the way
to realizing the dreams and ambitions
that you have now that bring more value
to you in this video I'm not going to
talk about how to find your one word
there's a process you can pick up the
book these videos I've made on at the
floor I want to talk about how to
maintain it consistently I want to talk
about how to make sure that you are
living it once you've discovered what
your one word is that becomes as bold
scary thing that you need to go off and
live every day and it's easy to fall off
the horse
so here are three ways to make sure that
you're actually living it consistently
number one is fine like-minded people
one of the biggest benefits of having
your one word and knowing what you
staying for is then being able to track
people who are like-minded people who
are like you people who believe the same
thing you believe you can't pick your
parents your parents were given to you
and they may share the same values that
you do or you may never want to be
anything like them but you can't pick
them everybody else in your life you get
the pick you get the pick who you go
into business with you get to pick who
your customers your suppliers are you
get to pick who you recruit onto your
team you get to pick who you end up
marrying and spending the rest of your
life with you're gonna pick these people
and most people don't know the filter
through which to attract people I say
I'm all about belief and for some people
that's amazing and they love it and they
can't wait to join and for others they
say that's stupid I want nothing to be
part of that amazing we wouldn't get
along anyway when you lead with your
core value start bringing people into
your life that help build you up that
are on the same mission as you and you
can go a lot further together like Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett number two is
your physical environment if you know
what your one word is you know what you
stand for then make your physical
environment a reflection of that when I
walk into my office every day this is
what I see these are the these are the
people that I see these people mean
something to me even wearing the shirt
like this is an automatic thing that
when I wake up and I come in here I get
an injection of believe but reminds me
and centers me on a daily basis when you
set up your physical environment the
beauty of it is that you only have to do
it once you do it once and then
automatically it triggers it triggers it
triggers belief for me every day what is
your one word and what does the physical
expression of that look like from the
environment that you're working in from
what you wear on your body to the
background on your cell phone and your
computer screen set up your physical
environment to trigger your one word
every single day and number three is
your habits and your routines you are
what you consistently do so if you
understand what your one where it is
then how do you get that on a daily
basis so for me it's believed I get it
through my videos I get it by making the
videos watching the videos creating the
videos sharing the videos everything
that I create is always positive it's
always believed worthy is always seen
through the lens through the glasses a
believe and that's how I stay centered
and focused on my mission every single
day now you might not be a content
creator awesome there are other people
who are embodying the believes that you
want on a daily basis and so if you
watch one of the videos on my channel
and you learn about some new
entrepreneur like Naveen Jain that
you've never heard of before
you might dive deep into his world if
Naveen Jain represents the one word that
you want to be living every day then
start your day within the bean Jain
video find out he's written a book see
if he has any articles like every single
day the habits and routines that you
have for yourself will allow you to live
your one word and so especially the
first 30 minutes of your day stop waking
up like an accident
plan your first 30 minutes of every
single day to inject that one word core
value into you to make it feel more
important to make it feel mission-driven
because you can have the greatest day on
a Tuesday and wake up Wednesday and poof
all that energy momentum is gone but now
you know how to inspire yourself now you
know how to drive yourself forward now
you know how to stay motivated it's
through the lens of your one word and so
know what that is and then design your
habits and your
teens around it so you feel it on a
daily basis in the first 30 minutes of
waking up now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you but before that
question of the day I want to know how
are you applying your Wan word core
value on a daily basis leave it down the
comments below I'm curious to find out
curiosity is not so much a trait as a as
a situation you put yourself in
situations where questions occur to you
I don't think you I'm less enamored of
the notion that some people are
inherently curious than others or not I
mean a my accountant might be a very
curious person but it's not in a job
that that invites curiosity in fact we
don't want him to be curious we want him
to be by the book and it yeah so I I'm
someone who has been in a curious
position for much about like exposing
yourself to things that will prove you
that will potentially prove your
preconceptions wrong so I'm like make a
very conscious effort to challenge what
I believe nothing makes me happier than
when I change my mind
my definition personally of creativity
is that it's the intersection between
humans labor and the mysteries of
inspiration which is kind of grand but
my definition of creative living is much
simpler creative living is any life that
you live where your decisions are based
more strongly on your curiosity than
your fear that's that's it and if you
consistently habitually routinely at
every sort of intersection and decision
in your life make decisions that are
based on curiosity rather than fear then
you will be engaging with creativity at
some level at some point and it won't
look like my life and will look like
your life it'll it won't look like
anybody else's life because everyone's
curiosity is different
so everybody's path the following
curiosity will have a different outcome
but um your life itself will sort of
become a work of art if you can
consistently live that way not easy but
so worth it so worth the trouble what
inspired this story for you I just
wonder you know I'm always my interest
is always like what haven't I seen you
know some guys watch stuff what I want
to do a movie like that and I watch
movie so I go okay I don't want to do
that cuz I saw it now what can I come up
with and I haven't seen this movie
you know and I really haven't seen this
movie with a black person yeah I mean so
that's me it's you know it gets me into
trouble sometimes but I'm just kind of
curious that way like okay can we see a
new movie yeah you know raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that passion and not one drop
of my self-worth depends on your that's
something serene if you guys want to see
the video that blew up my channel the
first the very first believe video is
sitting there right next to me go click
on the link continue to believe and I'll
see you there the common belief the
universe will believe because it had
been tried again and again and again